years resolutions to set and then maybe
not follow don't do that
one goal many of us have each year is
trying to stay healthy or even just
get healthy but with the social
distancing measures that are in place
right now that becomes a bit of a
challenge
this morning we have bianca holman live
at uh one gym
with some tips on how to reach our goals
bianca good morning
hey good morning john so yeah we're at
the game changer sports gym
uh here in las vegas and so you know a
lot of people you may have gained a cove
at 20
those 20 pounds and your your jeans are
feeling a little tight like mine right
now
and of course the holidays didn't make
it any better so that's why we're here
we're joined by ilsa martinez
and so i understand i've heard that abs
are made
in the kitchen right so it starts with
what we eat yes
um so it's very important to make sure
that we're eating all our fruits and
vegetables which are
very healing and it's medicine to our
bodies so one of the things that i do is
i supplement and make sure that i take
my fruits and vegetables using
juice plus okay it bridges the gap it's
all natural ingredients it's
gluten-free vegan so that's one of the
biggest ways that i help
boost that part of my health wonderful
and so what is this here i know if
there's some moms and dads out there
maybe you got a trampoline for the kids
in the backyard looks like you could
probably use this for a workout too
right yep so this is a mini trampoline
it's very affordable you can put it
anywhere it's portable
and what it does is as you jump and
bounce it helps cleanse your lymphatic
system
and get yourself going gets the toxins
out raise your body of
any uh toxins it nourishes your cells
it oxygenates them increases lung
capacity so it's very very beneficial
for any and you can do anything kind of
moves that you can do on the ground
you jump into it you can go into jumping
jacks so many different moves you can go
high knees
wow it takes some practice so definitely
you're going slow at first
wow this is all great so you know adding
those supplements in getting your
vitamins boosting kind of your immune
system and doing something like this can
definitely help people kick-start those
absolutely wonderful absolutely well
thank you so much we're definitely going
to have we got more things we're here at
the game changer sports uh
gym so we definitely want to talk with
more people here about what you can do
to jump start those health goals here in
2021 don't lose hope
back to you guys in the studio bianca it
starts now
this is the motivation for for alex and
sharing